Tenemos resultados prácticamente al 99% del escrutinio,
resultados definitivos de las elecciones vascas.
El empate técnico entre las 2 fuerzas nacionalistas
se ha mantenido Leticia desde el primer minuto.
Así es, los escaños se Han peleado
voto a voto en los 3 territorios,
pero el partido nacionalista Vasco
mantiene su hegemonía en número de sufragios
y obtiene incluso más.
El candidato Imanol pradales cosecharía
ahí lo tienen
27 escaños, Baja 4 respecto a 2 020.
En cuanto a e. H.
Bildu no consigue el sorpaso electoral,
aunque empata el número de escaños
con el p, con el PNV en
27 y lo hace en Buena medida porque se había
aprovechado de que podemos pierde 6 escaños,
queda fuera del Parlamento Vasco.
Los socialistas vascos, con Eneco andueza,
mejoran sus resultados y consiguen
asegurarse 12 diputados
en la cámara autonómica de Vitoria.
Los resultados son Buenos para el partido
popular y para su candidato
Javier de Andrés.
Sube 1 escaño,
ahí lo tienen hasta los 7
y sumar es 1 de las novedades de estas elecciones.
La lista encabezada por Alba García consigue 1 escaño
y desplaza a podemos en esa franja del electorado de
izquierda y por último,
ahí tienen Vox eh con otra mujer,
con Amaya Martínez
se queda como estaba hace 4 años,
con 1 escaño y 1 diputada.
Ella misma y si vamos 1 poco más allá,
aquí lo tienen.
El otro titular de la noche
es que el PNV y los socialistas
vascos podrían repetir gobierno de ¿Coalición
en ajurianeo? Pues sí,
porque sumarían 1 escaño más de los que
exige la mayoría absoluta
para poder elegir
al Nuevo leendakari,
es decir, a Imanol pradales, que sustituiría en ese cargo
a Íñigo Urcuyo